[Music]
what up how you livin how you doing how
you grueling it is the lef koe min and
we have ourselves our very first and
very special Wednesday roundtable you
know Brian Westbrook hey rocket man sup
what's going on man who's joining us
today Brian a little someone special hmm
someone very very special thank you
thank you man that's right yeah
the I'm so excited cuz I haven't even
previewed this at all yeah I don't like
to preview guests just in case you
canceled on me and then I would be like
oh that sucks
yeah um I'm gonna ask a question and
then I'll let you get into your story
cuz I knew your very first you got to
look at the t-shirt you got to talk
about this this is a great search 1975
from Jackson State Walter Payton
that's him getting the draft call this
is a true story this is perfect this is
perfect back in the day when I was in
college I won the Walter Payton Award
how great Division one double-a version
of the highest yes so any by this time
Walter had passed away his brother was
there I didn't know in his mom it on
your shirt you didn't who did you think
I was did you have a theory and she was
like I bet you that was a really funny
comedian the Bears were gonna take you
look at that and that cool that ISM this
is my idol when I was growing up I used
to watch all the videos the headband yes
the shoes alright so what was that last
time you saw Brian Westbrook I'm so glad
you asked because it is good to see you
but it's great to see 36 because the
last time I saw Brian we were
celebrating our Eagles yes winning the
Super Bowl
let me tell you literally brisson don't
you leave we were on the base of the
rocky steps right during the victory
rally and I'm running around and there's
Kapali and there's Wentz and there's
Falls and here's Westbrook and we hugged
and we bonded in the joy of our Eagles
finally winning a Super Bowl what do you
think of that what do you think of that
I mean you were your liberal use the
word our house that's a bond that you'll
never have the
talk about it 36 that's a bomb we'll
never be able to share it's moments like
this that bring your friendship together
all right Kyle thanks guys it's been
real follow me on Twitter so it did
share an embrace at the rocky steps we
did fantastic we did I never get that
moment first time he was on I had to
admit that the fact that he was embraced
as the Eagle guy in media angered me so
much i jacked it from you cuz you're
just such a liars fan I know that really
I didn't think that was gonna impact me
and I felt that sorry I have another
shirt that has a deuce Daly getting his
draft call where that next time two more
Eagles loss okay 22 I'm wondering you
guys are the same age you went to
college at the same time you went to
Villanova yeah you went to Princeton uh
was Villanova afraid to play the Tigers
is that why I'd never have whoa whoa now
because I know you both hate Penn pan I
hate with the pass you don't have a
problem with Penn know Delaware's our
rival Penn
Oh in a different way classic pennant
when I was there was like the U of the
Ivy League right you know a lot of guys
with gold chains with horns on them they
talked a lot after a little dirty they
beat the crap out of us we were really
bad we were and we had nothing for
Bryan's Villanova team Princeton that's
it I used to train up there at
Lawrenceville now Louisville and I was
coming out of college yeah it's a train
up there at the little the school
Lawrenceville Pratt Morris my roommate
was from there yeah every doggone day
State or the hotel was there for weeks
did you just training up there that's
right that's my man I wish we would have
played your team you guys were best by
50 though mine would have been fun
though you get drunk at the parade oh
look I've already told like I've got I
got you I mean you supposed to write you
put up a couple of drinks you just don't
know what like former players do like
fans that was our release that was like
yeah for a former player like it I
didn't get drunk I had a beer or two but
I didn't get a drunk nose you have a
moment where you this is I shouldn't I'm
sorry
mmm oh no were you like looked at the
people on the stage and you were like
[ __ ] backup safety I should be honest
there was a moment at the game at the
right after the game I'm like they're
gonna win this thing and I'm like man I
should have won this you had a little
bit I mean you're look at me because as
a player's natural it just natural that
you want that team I'm happy for the
team I'm happy for the guys but I kind
of want it to be me I'm gonna
be happy for me too there was a lot of
your teammates there that day I mean a
lot of your absolute and you guys were
thrilled for him but like that had to be
a little bit no you want it to be you
you're happy for other people but you
want to be a part of the fun too yeah
and unfortunately we right just no I I
had put in like three long weeks as an
Eagles fan so to finally have that
payoff after I think was like more like
twenty days just sort of three weeks
yeah it was very validating for me well
the Eagles fans embrace you I know I
mean the Eagles Nation embrace you they
kicked you out they kick let's do four
quid deverel do you like course I don't
know kids I have no clue probably just
messing around somewhere but quois a
hilarious dude everybody talks about
Thai I was a coy guy in November family
I liked it was great it was great how um
how you doing much for Biscay right now
like as a barrel do whisky not your
biscuit yeah that the hottest take of
the week I mean it really has some heat
on it is the Bears are better with Jay
stands [ __ ] it's nonsense and
there's a lot of people saying it I do a
weekly call with the Chicago radio
station every single week their callers
are saying screw it don't care if true
risk is out this is better I got asked
that by a Toronto radio station they're
like are they better and I was like did
you guys pass out a pamphlet of awful
NFL takes this week everybody loves the
backup quarterback no matter if they
play good and everybody loved AJ Feeley
everybody loved koi mmm you love the
backup because you're not satisfied with
the starter I think your expectation is
so much higher for him and it what's
funny is is all of that confidence goes
away after the first play
it's like you see them draw back and you
look at chase Daniel you go you can't
make that 5 yard out throw at Allen
Robinson every time I know chase Daniel
doe has something as an athlete that I
think is really rare
he's really familiar with what he is and
what he's not like he knows there's a
skill an athlete can have about playing
within themselves like you ever play
pickup ball and like the biggest guy on
the court like always wants to shoot 3s
always and it's like dude go to the low
block and get rebounds chase Daniel
knows exactly what he is not sure Biscay
I don't think even really knows what
he's as a player yet he feels a little
like Bambi on the ice but chase Tina
comes in he's like look I'm gonna do
this this this and that's all I got if
you like it let me play it now you know
that's from years of being a backup you
this is what I do well I'm gonna just go
do that sure Biscay still thinks that he
could be a legitimate starter and I
think I'm obviously he is I started
he just talent-wise I proven I think you
don't know the first half of that
sentence Mitchell too risky still thinks
yeah and that's what I see when I see
Mitchell sure risky play is he's still
thinking about the plays he's still
checking the arm and Chase is gonna go
in there and go I got it I was Drew
Brees is secretary for a few years you
know I've and then I went up and I
talked carson wentz everything he knows
he knows this offense inside and out and
they might be able to run more plays
which might help the running game and
maybe he's better at checking out the
line of scrimmage but I look at your
defense and I said this Monday I think
they're a top-five side of the ball in
the sport right now yeah it's ER Kansas
City's offense the Bears defense I think
can win you guys nine games by
themselves no no
and if chase can just set up a running
lane for four David Montgomery they have
a chance I think you guys beat the [ __ ]
out of a other Raider
I think it's a 25-point with you even
with Jace Daniel at quarterback I did
yes
Khalil Mack is gonna go out there and be
like apologize to Derek Carr after the
game the good thing about chase Daniels
is they eat Daniel day is that he's
gonna run the offense as it's designed
yes you're not gonna a blip he's gonna
be three-step drop ball out whether it's
a completion or not he's gonna run it as
you design it and that's that's that's
cool for the receivers that's good for
the offensive line same thing put
orphans coordinator you know exactly
what you're gonna get the problem is his
upside is just yeah it's long it's like
here it's like that tiny house is show
on HGTV I know what you said Bryan
though is perfect because there's also
something going on with Chase Daniel
right now he's first team All name
mispronunciations yeah there's a chronic
thing CPS on there why not
of course there should be an ash that he
knew it it's annoying I apologize again
he said chase Daniels a blipping and I
was like yeah yeah yeah see that's great
right so but I would admit something cuz
I just said something when I read that
quote on Monday about Andy Reid saying
that Mozart had paintings yeah I [ __ ]
animal idiot I love it
no but I was like it's art had paintings
of course he has he sold it did you say
with conviction
it worked nobody knows yes Jackson
Pollock had incredible symphonies person
your career and if you just sell it like
that yeah that's it but it's there's
something funny with with Khaleel Mack
all right so he's going to London he's
going against the biggest offensive
lineman in the league Trent Brown the
highest paid to go back to the
bears-packers opener I got to be at
Soldier Field I got to be on the field
well before the game and I see Khalil
Mack from across the field and he's
still in streets okay it's well before
the game and he's guys huge he's got
this shirt on that has like the K M logo
like custom-made or whatever as I call
that's Cologne Mac I want to walk over
to him and as I get closer and closer I
go wait is that Khalil Mac and that guy
was you I know you from the network get
over here and I walk forward the
gentleman that I was talking to was
Khalil Mac's father oh wow Sandi Mac is
his name and I believe me when I tell
you he looks exactly like Khalil Mac
same stature same biceps same face
everything but like a hugely gregarious
personality it's like as if it was spice
Adams personality put in Khalil Mac's
body you got to see this guy because my
mind immediately went to something Sandy
Mac that's a great name what's your name
sandy Maxx sandy like if you could - is
there a better ever father son more and
more physically intimidating combo like
if you're playing chicken in the pool
chicken fights that's exactly right and
don't forget Khalil Mac and Derek Carr
would have epic basketball battles in
the pool when they played an oak that's
true they talked about it every
offseason that's when I give a [ __ ]
about and so they were and Derek Carr
would always say he would dunk on Khalil
Mack so now I'm imagining sandy Mack
Khalil on top you think I think so I
think I need to see what Aaron Donald's
that looks like the Baron Donald what
have we keep it on the Bears you what if
it was the Mac father-and-son you take
Kyle long really how we that's [ __ ]
Waller because I I started thinking
immediately of Kyle and Bob Brant and
we're over in two seconds yes what about
Adam and Bruce left go how would they do
against the mask did you know Mike I do
my research to left going you
I thought your dad's name today - yeah I
think it would be he would have a lot of
we would have a lot of strategies a
group they would fall apart immediately
yes what about Tariq and moisha Cowan
I'll leave that joke to you but I don't
know tareka I think would have to be on
top right you guys listen up on Cheerios
legend of Tariq Owen as that was like
six five if it's that I recommend that
all Bears fans or football fans Google
Sandee Mac you need to see this
gentleman it looks and he could do a
Freaky Friday with his son not his twin
his son it's amazing
alright so this is the first time we've
done a roundtable on Wednesdays Kyle
you're kicking us off and the idea is is
that there isn't a host there are just
topics and they're not just very intense
football questions there are also ones
about life I have topics in the jar
we're each gonna pick in burr helped me
come up with them but first we have some
social lubricants as they would say to
get it going
these are topics that meaning burr would
say with people on the road in burr came
up with these and it tells you a lot
about personalities first one is Thanos
and cheese got it you have all the power
in your fingers when you snap every
cheese in the world goes away except for
one for every human in the world what
cheese are you keeping I'm gonna I'm
gonna go blue cheese
you're a [ __ ] seven I'm crazy it's
inevitable the crumbles I like the blue
cheese crumble Brian are you being
serious yet serious you won't even die
for blue cheese yeah I do
so you're turning every pizza into a
blue cheese a shame people are reaching
for pre-shoot and blue cheese do you
know what you've done
yes it's just disappointing that should
be l EU by the way would you spell it
properly Daniel of cheese that's from
what is sure what is the cheese that you
would kick well I'll tell you this I
hate cheese okay all cheeses yes except
for mozzarella cheese and oh man that is
the correct answer the pizza that's the
only place it can be sleep over here ma
no cheese I hate cheese what's up with
that why
literally hey cheese I hate American I
hate the with American the yellow one or
cheddar cheddar I hate that I hate all -
you don't like a taste or it back to you
so you'd only gonna like the taste I
don't like it Greek pizza I like pizza
mozzarella that's it my answer it is the
most versatile it could be used the
house place who spent three weeks
thinking about this question tell me why
mozzarella is the best seconds what do
you got why is it the best is the best
cheese because it maintains the most
important food groups and you don't lose
anything it can be eaten by itself it
can be eaten on a pizza Oh chatter
sounds great I don't want to [ __ ]
change the taste is the Frank Gore of
cheeses Oh blue cheese is I'm charting
of a player that's wildly specific and
upset so much Cam Newton of cheese's I
think it has its moments of being
perfect with a wing but other than that
no matzah we get blue cheese doesn't
you're telling me that you would look at
like a block of blue cheese and see the
green and be like I'll eat that straight
I'll buy it right out of it you know I
think I think it's the Gardner Minshew
of cheese different it's wild it works
see like mozzarella to me is I'm trying
to think of the most boring player in
the league mozzarella it's a safe answer
it's fine it's threaded it's another bit
like it's got no kick to it I would
expect someone like you at least go
pepper jack but I'm looking out for the
whole world I'm worried about me the
world come there are three candy bars
all right snap my fingers yeah you have
to get rid of one of them
Snickers Three Musketeers Reese's Cup
Westbrook you lead Reese's
we'll never be in my presence I don't
want it around me first of all there's a
thanks guy peanut butter chocolate
Carl's face peanut butter chocolate nab
go together watch they stayed
together I'm just gonna let you know
will you sit down for a second oh come
on peanut butter and chocolate should
not be together in the same place at the
same time that peanut peanuts in
chocolate yes little caramel in there a
little weight when we finally say things
low not Stefon Diggs go together like
chocolate and peanut butter like a nut
job
no ways peanut butter and jelly that's
what they go together like cheese and
wine not peanut butter in choc don't you
remember the old commercial back that's
wrong Reese's where there's a guy
walking in the mall and he's eating a
candy bar and there's a girl and
inexplicably she's eating peanut butter
in the mall and they turned the corner
run into each other and the peanut
butter goes on the chocolate you're like
wow you got a YouTube they should've
never made that they don't go together
and what Reese's yeah good how do you
say it no when people say Reese's I
don't like it is the best candy there's
a lot of people that making the mistakes
out there like you disappoints you're
gonna tell me that bran flakes is the
best cereal of all no the best candy I
would say Kit Kat Snickers are their
Milky Way Milky Way is a second worst
so is Reese's then Milky Way just sayin
have you ever tried the Reese's egg cuz
the peanut butter ratio is greater than
in the cup you know what's bad here's a
funny thing now Reese's dates so I've
said this on Twitter plenty of times
that's why I'm bringing it up and I've
been angry at myself for three weeks cuz
three weeks I've been wanting to yell at
you or figure out your brain and today's
the day because I'm a principled man and
I stand beside my facts the thought
process resis actually sent me a box
full of little peanut butter cups
t-shirts and everything and I and I've
just forbid my family this is absolutely
true from eating it said therefore you
are taking your preference to your three
kids and yet none of them will enjoy
Reese's they didn't eat it for a long
time they just one day they they
disappeared the t-shirt they're wearing
a t-shirts now the candy wrappers are
throwing around on the floor what you
need to do is this is good social media
is you take a Reese's Cup and you
the correct way to eat a Reese's yeah
and then you show and then you put it in
the trash trash it that's a good video
that would be good
put it on your feet I'll take all that
and Brian Westbrook Eagles legend
doesn't like cheese in rhesus I heard
you're also not a fan of a beer Saxon
breaking bad beer terrible wow that's
some takes Brian recently wrote an
article that you were the peanut butter
to the deuce daily chocolate do you have
any other weird food things let's just
clear that bread cheese is no good
yeah bro k we got something um peanut
butter and talk just don't go together
I got think of some more love cilantro
cilantro I do like cilantro which stirs
no no no no because a couple bad
experiences sure you put a little peanut
butter on that it's all baby you you
have what to me or as it turns into a
bathroom trip I'm just gonna say that my
two warm-ups I was not expecting an
argument about Reese's and blue cheese
this is great tile you are the guest
reached into the cup grab one all right
here we go I'm gonna reach into the cup
do I read it or you want me to hand it
over all right
they didn't your best game show host
food this all right there we go what's
the one tweak you have to make the NFL
better what should we do to make the NFL
better one tweak guys so we all have to
come up with what's one thing you want
to change about the NFL okay if you come
up with one right away uh I got this
idea okay they've had so many problems
with pass interference I think they
should make it reviewable what if they
could look at Pastner when that just
fixed everything if they can admit but
say it appear to be passing friends all
you have to do is flag it and look at I
think that'll work great they should
really guys how bad is this thing grow
it's the worst there's a guy that's
crazy
I watched Thursday Night Football with a
Packers fan go on when the Eagles
cornerback I think was Vonda Maddox
Joseph into the chest of marques Valdez
scanning and they were like now no
penalty I I said there was like this is
what what system are they [ __ ]
running right I think in a weird way
River on is worried about embarrassing
his referees by changing too many calls
I don't know what's going on it's not
making the game fun there's too many
stoppages
they said at the beginning of the year
there's a chance there's only lasted for
a season I hope so
the worst part is you think right you go
to the interview I mean you go to the
review and you're like hold on time out
everybody knows is passing the fairs
yeah except for the ref yeah that's
you're like it's been blatant so like
come on these are out the idea that was
that they're safe they have the rule and
not for any of this nonsense it's for if
there is another huge play in the
playoffs it's like a cyanide pill like
we have it if we need it but I think
this could go down is like one of the
worst rule changes that when it's NFL
150 or whatever we'll look back on 2019
like remember when you could review pass
interference like remember when the NBA
changed the ball and they made a
complete and shaq lost his [ __ ] and was
so mad abut and they're like this is the
stupidest thing ever go back to the old
ball this pass interference thing sucks
it's all I got and I love al river on
I've met him several times he goes on
Twitter and he says there was no
discernible blah blah blah he always
sends owl he writes his name in the
tweet which is a weird thing to do
Hulk Hogan does it too it's a kind of a
strange thing when people sign their
tweto is from you we know that you don't
need right now like Engler has a fewer
he wants to get rid of kickoffs in
verbally kickoffs absolutely Murr
believes that you should always have to
go 4-2 every time every time it gets a
little XF Valley when you start saying
you have to go for it like the dan
Cortese affectation it becomes an MTV
shock-jock yeah you got to still make it
a little big 'no fied every time you
can't kick extra points anymore come on
i in a weird way this is a little bit
reaction to the rams I don't like how
much time the coach is having the
headsets sometimes I wish that it was
like the college thing where they had
four pictures on the board the most fun
it's just a lot of fun but also there's
just I like a much of the Bengals on
Monday night and I'm watching Andy
Dalton get out there hard count and then
they all it's like watching Baylor
looking over the side it's just they can
communicate so much it's taking I don't
know that sound good there is a thing
with with naggy and the Bears would sure
Biscay that he's talking to him way into
the play clock and it's just short of
being like throw it to Burton like it's
almost like remember Madden back in the
day when they're little passing windows
and it was like XY and Z and the guys
waving his hand it's almost the point
where the coach can tell them who to
throw to - it gets doesn't it your
players that have no ability to read the
defense's you have no ability to read
coverages you're kind of handicapped and
guys here's my idea yeah I think you
could do it just has been frowned upon
so much that guys are just so
specialized I think that every game for
every team you should have at least five
guys that play offense and defense to it
what you have to have two-way player
talk about me you will you you have to
help me you're telling me that some of
the best athletes in the game Odell
Beckham jr. he can't play cornerback
mm-hmm you talking all this trash okay
now I you ever checked me and now you
have to do it the other way
oh the linebacker gets a hit on the
running back and guess what now the
linebackers are running back and I get
to go hit them mm-hmm how about that I
think you should get penalized if your
celebrations aren't good so is there
like Simon Cowell or yes 15-yard penalty
it is incredible I will say Brian and
here's one of the let downs of the game
is like if the Bron dunks like on Kauai
I like it that immediately let's get
guard cool
that's mark you know I mean like there's
there's no people used to freak out
about oh it's Eli versus Peyton sati
live versus pay and they don't play each
other they just stand on the other side
of the field
I would love some genuine back and would
if quarterbacks get on the other side
and now they're a DN right and now you
can go different type of athlete in
those positions now I'm just saying now
do you like the rule better if the other
team gets to choose which player and at
what time in the game or do the own
teams get to be like will put Odell yes
I like it both ways first of all we'd
like to put Sam Bradford it's safety for
the defensive tackle for the Eagles
Westbrook you pull will you go on this
is crazy get a good one now the bad part
is I know Adam has made these all up so
he wants a lot of these are in burr
creations great anchors the best if you
were involved in a massive bank heist I
thought I want more game show host the
end of you here we go dick - I the bad
part is that was my game or a little bit
more okay all right guys
you're just talking like a white guy
that's your game so talk like Steve
Harvey yeah I would do this not named
Steve Harvey for five thousand please
Alex we ready if we were involved in a
massive bank heist and everyone's code
name was different it was a different
international City what would be your
city name so this is off of the Netflix
show that I recommend to everybody
England - it's called money heist mm-hmm
and though they do not learn each
other's names they all have different
city names in the world so there's
Helsinki and they're all there and
they're Spanish there's debt Denver and
there's a Rio
what would your city name be I think I
would go to Cairo and I would do KY ro
cuz I'm Kyle Cairo
that's the ancients the cradle of
civilization we have the pyramids there
I heard it's kind of dangerous and I'm
serious
kai there's a Sphinx there I might be my
room I might be Melbourne Melbourne
Melvin that's it's an Australian cooler
Australia Barcelona Quebec is a good one
yeah it's not Quebec go back why why is
Quebec a good one what do you mean I
just in your eye teria city names that
have two syllables hydro yeah exactly I
think you nailed it I think is
incredible what about Westbrook what do
you think that's a good this is a
dumbass question first of course it is
this crazy voice that you want me to say
that a city name let's think about going
like Monte Carlo all my actions are the
same thing doing a piece of cheese I
would like Patrick mahomes city name be
though you would have to be fast paced
the exciting yeah Vegas oh this is a
pretty good city but you have to go
international that was for NASA I think
he'd be like a Monaco maybe Monaco or
what's the one in South Africa or the
his game because we talk about his gang
I'm saying Cancun it's a party town high
schoolers college kids drinking it's fun
like that let's do what city would Frank
or be Frank Gore has stood the test of
time this he would be Rome he's been
around for a long time he's just he's a
pillar in the community everybody looks
up to him he would if you could say a
navy will be the Coliseum that's what he
okay
Frank Igor I think I mean you go by
Jerusalem or something what's the oldest
Bethlehem we bring gifts of myrrh and
gold and Wiseman what would gardner
minshew s-- international name be the
jacksonville bags that's in the most
perfect city of all time right
it does it does the gardner mentioning
work if he's earned Myrtle Beach or if
he's in like Seattle or Green Bay I
don't think it works as well like
there's never been a city that's more
suited to it like a quarterback it's
perfect you can practically see him in a
lifted pick up in a tallboy energy drink
it's so great so Jacksonville it it is
Jack's and people don't realize like
people think Jacksonville is Florida and
they think it and it's more like how
much your job Georgia
it's the stem of Florida okay it's gross
I'll tell you this we played a Super
Bowl there no four right and so
everyone's like hey we're going to
Florida we're gonna remember that way
everybody's bringing t-shirts and shorts
and we get there and it's 50 degrees
freezing everyone's buying jackets
terrible Jacksonville sucks
just want to let people thought it was
gonna be Miami dama Florida yeah that's
gross it's good think of any other NFL
player that would be a who would be an
NFL player that'd be good at leading a
bank heist hmm Grady Brady would be like
well it set all our watches you know I
mean they would be very prompt breeze
would breeze would just think about it
and analyze it in yeah quarterbacks are
always gonna get a guard here a guard
there wit Nelson would be a perfect guy
to be you know sort of watch it what
about your guy Quinn and Williams he
would not be a good guy to have enough
he would be the kind of guy where the
whole heist falls apart because he's
eating too much and he didn't perfect
his radio
he actually wants to listen to a good
plan and like someone can we take a
selfie before you and he takes mascot he
does have one great moment where like
someone's running to go hit the button
turns the corner and gets knocked out by
running into Quinn in it moves like
buddy in the bank eyes though you need
one guy who's the muscle who comes in
and like kneecaps somebody to show the
bank you mean business that's what
Nelson or perfect too but perfect also
the guy and heat that kills the guy who
wasn't supposed to kill a guy yeah
waingro aggressive way to get it on
that's that's perfect you're right he
perfect has to get it on that's a great
call I'm trying to think who else would
be the really good Bank heisters like
who's who is tactical and mischievous we
need a guy on the safe the guy who's
gonna put the head thing on I have the
guy alvin kamara
is the one that bends over a million
times and squeezes that's good that's
good he's a guy you know ocean and
lemons that hit inside of the sandbox
that's it might be more Tariq to me you
think he's small guys that there's that
old movie with Catherine zeta-jones
entrapment where the whole movies just
about her bending her butt underneath
the lasers and god is it a great shot
that would be that to Rico in here I
mean under the lasers for Sean Connery
to gives jollies it's a creepy movie all
right what do we got next one more time
Catherine yes place another take no
trust
that's the same thing is my Montecarlo
exactly right yeah say welcome to the
rock now dawg
what do you got dennah day you're an NFL
owner okay you just fired your coach you
have to pick someone that's on
television to be your new head coach who
would you pick okay so there's a youth
movement now you got to go young who's
that guy from the baby driver movie and
cell Elgort his name
you see baby dragon see he's a great
looking guy he doesn't have much to say
it seems to be sort of like off-brand
Robert Pattinson
I'm gonna go with Ansel Elgort that's my
guy I have a text message
I got it look this guy yep question the
question is mainly for like TV analysts
but I said I'm purposely leaving it
open-ended because I don't know where KB
is gonna get so Elgort obviously these
guys wouldn't pick how he longed how he
longed yeah I've been talking about how
along recently why do you say that I
believe that I look at these coaches and
I I think that how we would be the guy
that would be able to be a very
disciplined but he would be like the
enforcer coach that stands on the
sidelines like Mike Tomlin doesn't
actually do anything he has no Cena DC
but I think he could lead groups of men
like right now like how he is so
disciplined as a human that I think he
would carry on well but I also think
that he knows how to interact with
athletes because of his sons you can say
my answers awful no no it is awful but
I'm thinking of a team
Kyle Brant would also be a great choice
to calibrate would be perfect as a coach
it's like the worst life of all no it's
a turbulence we're not telling the life
that were just so that's what I want for
you I'm thinking about start the Miami
Dolphins who would be perfect for them
who can step it up first of all it has
to be a comedian
okay right now they're a joke you're
mesmerized okay I will liked it I would
like to elect someone from Philadelphia
okay short in stature cool man but
hilarious Kevin Hart the Dolphins hosted
now this team will still be terrible so
they still had that going on but it
would be funny yeah but at the same
that's automatic at least you could be
fun I feel like when Kevin Hart doesn't
have original things to say which is a
lot I feel like he goes back and walks
out and so you're only gonna have him
for the coach for like a quarter the tag
line for that Joker movie it goes I
thought my life was a tragedy but it
turns out it's a comedy that could be
the Miami Dolphins it could be the funny
walk huh maybe the rock would be perfect
he was really good in that one movie
with troubled youth he's an Intimidator
he's big he could probably play and
coach at the same time I would say like
the rock and I used to do some his head
coach you bring out Shawn Carney he goes
welcome to the rock
usually have the team come out the
tunnel yes the team just doesn't come
out they the team they just go stand
there in the rock he will coach comes
out does it lose his wrestling thing
yeah he would give amazing pregame
speech coach Johnson what about I don't
know if you guys watch the succession
but what if the coach of the Dolphins
was Roman Roy do you seen a couple
episodes and every single person that
run into you says you gotta watch Kolka
the Koken oh yeah sure the guy who
pleasures himself against the window I
saw that soon yes really interesting he
goes for it that's the one thing you
don't but Smerch the show it's
phenomenal no it's great watching
nonsense HGTV yes Peppa is on it my wish
HGTV personality would be the best coach
of the NFL right now that's a great
question all right I'm gonna go Tarek el
Moussa which was Marco mousses the guy
from flip or flop who so frazzled though
gets real frazzle however they could buy
a one-bedroom tenement infested with
human corpses built on a Native American
burial ground and he's like turns out we
made $250,000 time to find another house
to flip
that show skull flipper pop they never
had a single flop in about 12 seasons
doesn't matter always make money I would
do the twins what are the twins names
are the property brothers yes yeah have
you ever ever heard the property
brothers country album go on youtube
their country singers dude property
brothers country singing it's on there
it's something because I won I think
that having twins coach a team you know
you can take a day off
let your twin brother come in so you can
actually be the only head coaches that
have normal sleep
you have an assistant coach built in and
you're always keeping people on their
toes yes this is an awful idea
the brothers one of them does the
construction and one of them does the
sales so you would have one coach
brother who does like I handle the X's
and O's and then I had to like the
personnel that actually could work one
actually does the coaching and the other
one just does the press conference I got
a perfect we got Ramsay there we go
we'll take your team from being average
to the next level he rips on all the
employees yes he's a Bill Belichick of
cheffing you're right that's who
you call this a bloody ruse my face
Ramsay would be perfect do you call that
moving the a gap like that's good that
Haggard catcher's mitt face of his very
intimidating it's the guy from bar
rescue
Oh Jon Taffer that's shut it down now
say the dolphin shut it down Taffer
it just makes Josh Rosen cry in the
corner yeah but hold on some people are
tapped for guys I'm a Robert Irvine guy
you ever see Robert Irvine dude he's got
lats out to here 6 3 2 80 throwing the
sledge I like Robert Irvine every cuz
you know what if I had Jon Taffer come
in I'd be like I don't know if you live
the advice you're giving him no Robert
Irvine is like every minute is being
used oh I love Robert that's a
fascinating question I want to ask Brian
something because I've had this
conversation a lot about like all right
full confession I finally said screw it
I have to spend a little money I hired a
personal trainer for the first time in
my life once a week Congrats it's very
expensive but I said I work on camera I
gotta get my my personal trainer is a
brick [ __ ] he looks like Robert a
massive built guy I've always been
fascinated by coaches who are woefully
out of shape because they demand
incredible physical performance and
dedication from their players yeah but
they don't examine it their self exhibit
a coach Reid was there anything to that
that like you guys have to be so ripped
and so dedicated but he's a massively
obese guy great coach Butler do they
ever lose any credibility thought about
Matt Patricia this yeah for sure after
practice Mark Mangino
those guys played for Annie forever I
love Andy so I think that we never
really never looked at them that way but
I can see your point because you have to
be disciplined to six pack it up and be
lifted and all that other stuff and Andy
was a detail oriented and I told this
story before the only thing that I ever
saw Andy my entire career was a salad
that's it I think I might have seen one
eat a cheeseburger one time I've never
seen him eat anything but a salad in the
cheeseburger so how what happened then
he goes home and I I just imagined that
in his private time he enjoyed meals big
peanut butter and chocolate guy he's
probably a lot of Reese's in his private
eye but I never saw it outside of mamita
room yeah you know cafeteria nothing but
salad so someone shows up to camp and
they fail the conditioning test yes and
nice and this is BS you got to get
yourself in shape get down and run it
again a like shut up fat man what do you
know about hitting the shale also assess
fines for being overweight damn to
dolphins are Muslim most least the
offensive lineman usually Christmas
hobby you know Thanksgiving a little bit
overweight and that's the part where I
go I never thought about this with Andy
because he was an offensive lineman and
there's something about the acceptance
of offensive lineman you you Andy put on
all this we get to keep him it's the
smaller stocky guys that like never
played no huh
that what business do you have right
right but but then we like you said like
the realistic nature of their jobs and
how they work so much and probably
they're just like eating at their desk
and all that but I bring up pizza into
the coach's room and have three slices
and there's a lot of coaches in the NFL
that never played football one that that
nervous that hard to get over
well no it's kind of weird you're like
well how do you know and the good ones
say this is where the whole for running
back this is where the whole should be
but you feel it figure it out for
yourself let me just tell you what you
should be doing what the area you should
be in and you to allow your skill level
to do it like my my running back coach
great coach Ted Williams he played
baseball never played football he was
great it was a great coach but he also
was like listen he knew his own
limitations like as a coach
listen I can just tell you where it's
gonna be an a gap a gap - a gap is your
landmark and just go do your thing
high running back coaches named Pedro
Martinez it's incredible coincidence
yeah I'm just kidding have you commented
deduce about the way he's put on and I
don't
and the deuces deuces one of my mentors
he's one of the guys I really respect
he's big bro he's gotten big I mean when
he went to Pittsburgh he probably went
from like 230 to 250 okay he needed a
path they were gonna take a pounding out
there in Pittsburgh and he's gotten
bigger since were you on the team when
Levon Kirkland I was that was my rookie
you came from Pittsburgh
yeah Devon Devon Kirk really he was 300
pounds yeah
back 300 pounds in and so I'll so what
happens in training camp you go against
the first team and he was a starting
linebacker at that point so I'm the
second team running back and you're the
first team and so there were times where
I had to try to figure out a way to
block this man what were you playing at
at that time were you I was probably 200
pennies to the coasters like they don't
they they would fast forward the part
where I tried to block him cuz it was
like what's really incredible is right
this is like 18 years ago yeah and
they're like I don't know if Brian can
stay in there and block LaVon Kirkland
and now we're like hey LaVon Kirkland
you have no chance of guarding this
running back in the flats right so it's
still at that time they're like we'd
have to work on Westbrook and it's like
no you're worried about this linebacker
that came on your line back you got to
block the line back that's how they did
it back then you could swished it in the
film like I said I would be the
linebacker he would be to run it back
and let's see if he could block me mmm
Jim saying do you think about that if
you lose right now like you see what
McCaffrey is doing like that was you
dude yeah that's the same thing yeah he
I never thought that Christian McCaffrey
was gonna develop to this level to lead
the league was a question you got all
the time when they finally moved on from
deuce the question that offseason was
can Westbrook handle the low that's
right cuz you were like a 100 carry a
year guy yeah and then it spiked up to
the 300 and in McCaffrey has done a
great job how much of a chip was on your
shoulder that I lent it every day
because I thought that I should have
been the first rounder I mean still to
this day and I'm not trying to toot my
own horn it's just don't do it man I am
well - - but I I lead the NC double-a in
yards from scrimmage period and I was a
good player but I the competition level
it wasn't anything about you know can
you play where you are you better than
all these other guys it's a competition
level right and so I kind of felt that
there was a chip on my shoulder in my
entire career because people are down I
was at the Senior Bowl an all-star game
and it also games everybody plays right
before we walk out coach comes to me
stump Mitchell I'll never forget because
I literally just like him to this day
he's like yeah no no you're only gonna
play your own punt return that's it mmm
I'm like this is it this is this is an
all-star game everybody should play no
no they just want to see you a punt
return that's it so your that's all
you're gonna do and we may put you on
third down from time to time you would
have been a thousand thousand guy now
man I mean you're incredible as it was I
did that at college
crazily who knows you could yeah I know
which is gonna happen
all right reach into the car I'm going
into the cup maybe I'll pull out
to girlies from this one cup let me see
here um sick Oh disgusting I never
watched it I wouldn't do it alright
you've never watched it no I never
actually when it got big I don't want to
tell Bryan's I don't know if he's seen
it now google it haven't I heard that it
had to do with digestive stuff and I
don't handle that well and it was a time
when like you watched it or you hadn't
it was like that videotape from the ring
at your show uh listen uh let's let's
keep moving oh they might give me a
voice to do it in the Saturday game show
ask them what type of theme you want now
I'd like it to be the beginning of are
you afraid of the dark kind of scary at
home news Fridays goosebumps okay RL
Stein if you could add one place as 900
number if you could add one player from
any team unto the Dolphins who would it
be
mmm okay do I have to go are you go
there's two ways to think about this one
I'll give you two of mine there's the
I'd love to put Patrick mahomes on the
Dolphins to see how many games he could
win with the same roster in him and then
there's a notion of sending someone to
the Dolphins as punished like sending
Burfict like no you're not suspended you
need to go play for the Delft go down so
there's two ways to kind of go like I
sent him to Azkaban it's like a prison
alright who would you who do you think
like other than my Holmes could you send
a quarterback down there that would
still have success could you send it to
Sean no no this is what you do what do
you got you say and I'm gonna use a
quarterback game coach you've had so
much success over the last 20 years
you've been so good
you've taken average players and make
them look great you've won Super Bowls
more than any wink accountant in New
England go on now
you go down there to Miami South Beach
Bill Belichick you go down to South
Beach Tom Brady
if find a way to win down there how
about this how about Belichick and Brady
now the ticket Brady alright so how many
games do you want to greatest yeah you
got you go win down there if there are
there are twelve games left how many
games did the Dolphins win if
immediately as of right now balichek and
Brady go to the
not a lot number compared to the number
that we think we think that they are the
most powerful duo that has ever lived
that that Bella check would walk in the
door and everybody would inherently get
better yeah and and as I said on Mondays
show this is two decades in the making
what Belichick has but but if you gave
him an off season hmm Oh his hands on
the roster the salary got even better
coach you have to take hard knocks down
there too and now you're in left goes
office you take your heart now you take
heart nocturnal and Jon Gruden down
there and just see how much he goes off
in the meetings knock if you with I
think I think GRU dinners is slowly
dying on the inside which Gruden are you
talking about oh great point John though
I saw a quote where it's like losing
perfect was really not good and I was
like oh wow he can't even speak it was
good he got 10 million bucks to do it I
mean if you put Khalil Mac on the
Dolphins yeah how much better does that
team get if Aaron Donnell marginally you
can avoid them you can kind of avoid
Mack kind of yeah certainly can't avoid
his father sandy but I honestly think no
clue max an interesting one because I
think he like wrecks the whole offense I
think I think and I and I want to say
this too we're talking about sending
someone to the Dolphins
I think the Dolphins would beat the
Redskins right now I think the Redskins
are the worst team in the league and I
saw today that Jay Gruden said that they
say what's your plan at quarterback and
he goes quote we don't really have one
right now it's an exact quote dolphins
would beat the Redskins by 10 points
right now because the the Dolphins have
a plan at least
everybody knows you know what I mean and
and I look at Jay Gruden Jay Gruden has
been come completely powerless when you
can't decide who's playing quarterback
for your team why would you even want to
coach anymore and and I look at that
franchise from the top down they are
worse than alpha Dave they are I had
this we had this question because so
it's the Haskins goes in mid-game which
I know you talked about this was
terribly executed and give him a clean
start prepare for the week they just
threw him in the middle of a game so now
they play the Patriots this week oh one
of the greatest defenses of all time we
still don't know what they're gonna do
the problem is if they play Haskins in
this game which I think that they should
because you can't like start opponent
dodging
you can't say well we would play it but
it's the Patriots let's waste to the
Dolphins that's lame however Haskins
against this Patriots defense it could
throw six interceptions like it could go
after only kid it could be Cataclysm
Broncos by 50 points but then what do
you start Case Keenum and then what if
Case Keenum again for us three Haskins
back game again playing Colt McCoy I
know and like he has been facing an
ongoing injury that the doctors of D of
the Washington Redskins can't figure out
because their doctors are [ __ ] awful
like I would rather play on the Dolphins
than the Washington Shark ins yeah
easily yeah Plus listen is on the way
out right I mean he has to be and is he
probably even that bitter about it
there's all this speculation he'll go
and join Jon Gruden they'll move to
Vegas which means next year Jay Gruden
won't be in Washington which will
probably be the worst year in human
history to be in Washington DC because
it'll be an election going on and it'll
be hell o other worse things go to Vegas
fine he'd be a coordinator you'll do
great
I don't I think he actually wants to I
think so too
I did not even think about the election
that is the saving grace for the
Washington Redskins about that is they
are gonna be such there the back page
for nobody even cares and they could go
in 16 or 16 I know it's not gonna be
about the president did you watch the
video the one I'm talking about yes you
did
yeah that was an era where that was the
first video where I saw reaction videos
become if they filming people watching
the video yeah sure yes I think I saw an
e bombs world back in the day that was
the lofty pop me to come on you got more
do you member the kid in the orange
sweatshirt that did the robot ani bombs
world that damn Daniel guy no no I'll
play it at the end I used to do the
sound boards with Robert DeNiro and
swore scenario so you're gonna do you're
gonna do a clown at a birthday party
yeah again all of my voices sound
there's AK saying so so don't do it
yeah Rushmore of angry runs
who's the guy who's the guy that's on
the Mount Rushmore of anger runs so like
it for angry runs we have to deduce all
the angry runs which is another segment
that you do in good morning football
that I really enjoy I enjoy that one I
enjoy Wall Streeters I don't know what
the [ __ ] you guys were doing
I can roll [ __ ] that was nuts was that
your idea no but we said let's try
something wild on a Wednesday and
everybody pretend to be a rock star and
just like call someone out who needs to
be a rock girl I tried to do it
Dave girls a talented guy I had no idea
until I was in the middle of second I'm
like crap this is balmy and this is
really hard
angry angry runs and Nate obviously does
Toto drag swag but if we had to deduce
it to four angry runs of all time are
there any that jumps in that are of
course okay what I mean you mean like in
the history of football or like in the
last few years okay Marshawn Lynch is
he's the Tracy Porter farm runs over the
shaking yeah you know what's funny about
that play is anytime they replay it they
always cut it on the network cuz he
grabs his balls at the end yeah so
whenever you see that ya home and they
always they stop right before he gets to
the end zone because they didn't want to
show that it was like this this money
should track 12 on the album is like
explicit all the sudden and they take
that off alright so I know that you
played and you're a phenomenal running
magnate kyle is the expert in this do
you accept marshawn's run against the
saints as one of your top four yes it's
in the Washington spot of the Rushmore
100% this is easy
would you like to submit hundred percent
I would like to submit every run from
the Marcus Dupree 3430 who was he
playing against I don't even know who
was the I would say if my real
submission would be Bo Jackson running
over Oz with Bosworth uncle I watch it
and I'm not that impressed but every
person that talks about it it was like a
a legacy defining truck stick yeah so
that's why I'm submitting it but it is
you're gonna know what Bosworth meant at
that time I'm seeing physical nasty
linebacker was mostly Oklahoma yeah yes
just he was the man the smartest thing
he did was sell like [ __ ] Bosworth
t-shirts my god I know genius marketer
you got at some point look into like the
oral history of the movie stone cold
that Brian Bosworth did fascinating
thing the sound bites from his agent
when they were trying to make him a
movie star are so good they're like the
first script was not passable
we wanted to Bozza fie it and that's an
actor you justify as a quote and we
think that Brian Bosworth is gonna take
Hollywood by storm it was so good
do you accept that as one of your four I
do not accept it I'll buy four and I'll
tell you why the angry runs that I look
at the context is not that importance
meaning that bow versus Bosworth was the
seminal moment in football but the pure
physicality of it I've seen much better
I throw up because I celebrate I don't
want just the stars I'm gonna do a
little more oh yeah what do you when ap
ran over William Gay 90% is that on
there hundred percent is that one
do you remember it I'll pull it up you
guys William Gay is he sit running over
he just was either corner of that you
ran over a Greg boy or something again
context doesn't matter I don't care
about the context but Bryan's bring up
something different which is the quality
of opponents that's right running over a
corner is different than running over
defensive I have a good one and this is
old-school let's watch let's watch this
one's really good oh yeah but listen for
spots all time it's a great one you're
right you're right like what I'm looking
for it let me one of them that it has to
make it is we go back before all of our
times the Earl Campbell in the dome head
down it crushed somebody's stirring
jersey ripped off still running that one
is 100 that's the Jefferson I wear the
jersey completely represent the powder
blue beautiful Oilers Jersey tears off
and if you look at it now I mean he
would be kicked out of the league for
doing it it's the crown of the helmet
right into this darkness and you can
just see the wind remember that old shot
of that cannonball going to that guy's
stomach in slow motion with the goggles
that's what it was so role is in
Marshawn isn't it also reminds me of
what was the football the soccer player
is sedan with a Nadine's a dime from
France and the World Cup head butted to
do that to me is one of those moments
was that pre-twitter yes that is one of
my moments that we felt like it was
trending and even though Twitter didn't
exist like we think there was all this
talk about JLo and the Versace dress and
how that invented Google Images Zinna
dan say his name is Anna Dean Zidane and
now he's like a manager of like a very
prominent Club but it was the image of
him
like this and he didn't run up he just
went and the dude oh yeah
he's like the picture of class and
respect in that sport and he just
completely lost like Roger Federer
instead of shaking the doll's head
head-butting him in the face yeah I was
a great mom so we have to so we have
Marshawn and Marshawn and Earl Campbell
and Brian I think you got more well you
stole my Eric Campbell or well camos
first-ballot it's easy but I think
sweetness okay has to be keeps I mean
there's so many of them
oh the cheese made me think of Christian
Okoye yet for some reason in my mind but
then he got Atwater he got P beat up a
little bit but Walter Payton you say I
can't think of one run in particular but
he ran over every button for Smalley run
it back
Google Walter runs through the Chiefs
anybody listening or watching his his
best run of his career was against the
Chiefs when he was a young player and he
broke about seven tackles on the play
that is the one and that is also
admitted it was not a touchdowns about a
17 yard run so someone that says Walter
Payton versus Kansas City chief that's
the one like this is the runs out to the
right eludes gets a very good starts
breaks a tackle breaks another tackle
breaks three four blowers oh I'm still
going man and this is young Walter young
Walter so good they were down they were
down three touchdowns at the time came
back to win the best part is that next
week they played the Vikings and he had
like 270 yards rushing in the game and
set the single game record Walter Payton
is in so you take us who is definitely
third you have another definite third
definite third is gonna be Payton
against the Chiefs okay so that's in
there yes I have a personal favorite and
it's Brian it's definitely one when you
were playing there is a game that was
49ers versus Jets overtime garrison
Hearst in overtime stiff-arm two Jets
safety and about a 90-yard touchdown run
to walk off as Mariucci went crazy on
the sidelines
that's a personal favorite of mine that
was a really good stefarr I'm thinking
about all the runs were Jerome Bettis
are flattened again but endure lacquer a
couple times first bad guy what about
when a Antonio Brown was returning a
punt jump kick the punter and kick the
putter in the face if we're talking
about angry runs your rights because
that was really cruel and mean to get us
under of all people about OJ and the
Bronco
I mean he was running angry he's running
angry with AC in the front seats right
there driving slows on the 405 right if
they were going over the speed limit yes
it made for a lot of jokes even to this
day about any time the Broncos have a
white guy you're like well that's the
slowest I've seen a white Bronco go
since the 405 I love those jokes Brennan
spoke leaves to get some Athene Hillis
probably had some angry runs or his
precursor Mike Alstott had some angry
runs my first thought yeah
flattened humans Mark Ingram right now
is one of the great anger we were having
a conversation on the bra on the
Dolphins this year I think might be the
best this year it won it one angry runs
on the show there's been some knocks
you know Dawson Knox was the next week
and I give you a producer tip yeah you
should have a carry over and they should
have to compete with the the week before
tried this and I'll tell you why it was
tough
do you remember years ago yes when for
six years what from the last for six
years and it's really funny because Mark
Sanchez does this and finally ESPN said
we're retiring it we have to do the
second we have to carry on we had a
moment like that last year if you
remember on Monday Night Football Vance
McDonald dealers ran over Chris Conte be
the greatest anger run ever that's
probably on the Rushmore
and for like two months we played it and
we're like we gotta just retire because
it's never ever gonna get beaten so we
used to serialize it alright so I'm
gonna give you a different producer note
then you should have like a Hall of Fame
where these are the untouchables and if
you notice like if it's if it wins like
four or five weeks in a row
I think it goes into the ring of anger
it's too good you got another one I have
another key you have an angry run do you
have one we're used to farm the [ __ ] out
of somebody's we played San Fran this is
early on ok
and I bust this long run and was me and
Mike Adams who actually went to Delaware
we played against each other in college
and he's trying to tackle me and I give
him a nice stiff arm
they just me and him huh stiff arm down
the sideline I don't think he falls he
goes backwards obviously gonna end up
score but it was a pretty good run it
wasn't necessarily angry but it was a
nice physical run I had another run we
up here planning Jets we're what does
their own linebackers name Bangkok's
count no no no no no he was it he used
with the
Oh Velma yeah Jonathan bill okay reason
one the sideline in it was rare because
I don't that wasn't my gang running
people over but I'd like to take an
angle and then when you have a weak
shoulder take you down hmm so I shook
him a little bit got the angle and boom
ran them over on the side I talked a
little trash did you wasn't my game but
kind of a trash talker where you like
what you say some things you probably
shouldn't repeat on any televisions
[ __ ] ugliest yeah chocolate and peanut
butter no baby it was all bad yeah do
you have do you have an angry run in
your life that that you harken back for
instance versus you yeah I would it's a
good guess I think mine was against
brown yeah battle of the brains
something like that I ran over a guy
against brown and I got to be really
excited about and Ross Tucker I know
who's been on the show was a guard at
the time yeah and he talked all this
[ __ ] for me he got in somebody's face
now he did it too so Brown and then back
in high school probably then we're
getting it happens that offensive
lineman talk [ __ ] sometimes for the star
players I think so don't you think no he
never did was Chad and Runyon walking
around below what John really it took me
it wasn't to my second the middle of my
second year before me and Jon Runyan
actually had a conversation really just
one day I was in the hot tub and he just
was like hey I'm coming to bring some
stuff over and you're gonna sign it up
that okay that was a comprar that was
the beginning of our relation when you
guys used to play in the national game
and you would say you know Brian
Westbrook Villanova he would always be
like Jon Runyan Michigan and it was so
all business and you know for no levity
at all she meant business John was the
nasty dude like I watched John I was in
the hot tub one day he slipped and fell
on the steps of the hot tub oh [ __ ]
broke his tailbone
what broke his tailbone now I don't know
if you have you guys ever bruised your
tailbone yes you can't walk on the eyes
you can't do nothing now you can't do
anything you can't really a fast one
time yeah yeah great job and so he plays
he plays the next week Wow he gets his
his butt basically shot up his tailbone
shot up every week oh my he didn't
practice at all he had to sit like one
of those little donut things yeah I mean
he's dead I have one look to be honest
your Walter Payton clipless career
it's not a top four of all time but you
got its very biased Derrick Henry's run
against the Jaguars on Thursday
yesterday for 99 yards where he
stiff-armed the entire roster which is
about the entire City of Jacksonville
the entire lineup of limp Biskit have
every single person he's different
99 yard touchdown so I would like to
figure out in your brain how did you get
to limp Biskit right there Lynn what is
about Jacksonville oyster farms got you
there I just want to slow it down
chocolate starfish in the hot dog
flavored water no I'm just thinking I
think that they're from Jacksonville I
think that Fred Durst @al are from
Jacksonville I think if they're not they
100% should be don't tell me they're
like York because Jacksonville yeah so
I'm saying I knew it I here's a run
here's a run what's oh this is your run
yes but for me face my you scored and we
always like it when you finish it - yeah
let's go did you just type in Brian
Westbrook highlights that's so cool what
did you type in to get that Brian
whispered highlights and his thanks link
has been visited 700 times making kids
watch it before they go to school what
moment in your life do you wish you can
have on YouTube and to show your kids
mmm that you are actually like why
merciful I haven't won that I don't like
that my real world experience as a like
shockingly light internet presence he's
not out there much there's not a lot of
pictures no I mean Google Images is not
kind to me but like I remember there was
a couple years back that they were
introduced they were doing some called
MTV classic and those great will run all
these old road rules seasons railroads
is like please don't ever run my season
again I think I'm in a co-ed shower at
one point I'm the confessional I was 22
I really hope that never comes out Kyle
you know what you know what swear I'll
of the real world
yeah Susan and I literally didn't
realize until just now that you own the
doggone real world that's it Chicago man
I remember that we aired in 2002 and you
watch that I was like the annoying white
guy like Kyle but I don't know there's
something wrong with him Dave Chappelle
made a skit about you hundred percent I
was basically the guy in the skit and I
was the world's like that actor yeah
I was like the the archetype of the guy
who comes into the show who like offs
the season do fragged my dad that was me
that was me you had you had the what do
you got let's see what should my voice
be comment oh I think it should be you
are a Sesame Street character hi curls
don't think just like a number
how many NFL coaches could you beat in
armwrestling that was don't think how
many coaches could you beat arm
wrestling right now say number go 10150
i could know your weight way to all the
young coaches all the young little
offensive coordinators Sami Bey is like
five six my stomach Vey has gone I could
not be charming vanam a containment
floor I like you called the Cincinnati
coach that's his name I don't need to
learn as the Cincinnati coach watch it
live and let me talk about Harvick I'm
watching the [ __ ] game and they're
down 21 points with five minutes left in
the third quarter and it's a crucial
third down and they bring Tyler Boyd in
to block a defensive end i sat here and
I yell at coaches that use tight ends to
block defensive and receiver they use
their best wide receiver and it looked
like the Bengals were running down the
clock on purpose coaches I think that is
the worst coaches is supposed to be the
fun year for Cincinnati Marv's finally
gone we're having a new change and it's
like it's like shake and Markham back
it's sort of like don't tell Mom the
babysitter's to sort of like think it's
gonna be fun
Christina Applegate the dishes are done
man let me think about the guys that you
know it couldn't be so Mike Vrabel
probably had got it he would beat the
[ __ ] out of him might break away was a
nasty player I remember playing he's
just like I'm not nasty please Carol in
a [ __ ] arm I'm not 7100 be twenty
years old I am not armwrestling Pete
Carril it's not gonna go well Pete
Carroll but he's also the guy that's
gonna do the over the top hat flip me
like I've been practicing always like a
switch
and he will he will not be chewing the
[ __ ] I'm just gonna lean into it
the guy that you don't wanna beat you no
wonder Lawrence looks like you mean
business but other than that like Maggie
now nanites accordion II don't think
that you get Bella check brood and I'm
not beaten Simon guess Rudin Gruden my
[ __ ] arm
I am sizing you I just turned into a me
thing yeah well you got a hypercolor
sweatshirt on that it's to distract you
it's good do you think you could be
Bruce Arians in arm wrestling contest oh
yeah sure like Bruce Arians is an older
gentleman yeah sure are you are you
someone that has arm wrestle lot in your
life you know okay but I have watched
over the top many men myself into
situations Bruce get over here come on
put your arm here Jason put your arm on
the table Sean Peyton would kick my ass
do you remember the arm wrestling scene
from the fly which you have Goldblum do
you ever see the fly no Jeff Goldblum
arse any as the powers of a fly and he
breaks someone's arm completely in half
it's completely disgusting you got to
see it do you after the show
yes what power do flies flies again one
of those things where they can carry
like ten times their own weight or
something like that so when he becomes a
fly it was very powerful okay so here's
the thing you guys aren't being variable
you're not beating
Anthony Lynn like that son Dan Quinn
would rather die than lose to you but
like the Doug Peterson's novel Shanna
he's easily easily got him [ __ ] floor
easily who would you rather arm-wrestle
Doug Peterson or Kyle Shanahan I I think
Shanahan Kenny but he's I feel like he's
in shape Peterson is a big man but like
work on five Doug doesn't give like
Shannon does like Orangetheory or
something trendy like but also Doug
Peterson was a quarterback and I think
their arms are naturally stronger than
ever
else's arms and Kyle like I've seen him
out like I can take him you can take him
I just think he probably has that other
gear that I don't I'm pretty sure you
could take Shaun McVeigh to he maybe
Jack but he's still small I saw Sean
McVeigh in a bar I don't want to bench
press against short people and I don't
an arm-wrestle because you guys have
such a better escort that is because
your arms are so short yeah yeah like
I'm the Vince Vaughn of media at this
point it's a true you are alright my
turn
yeah all right here we go I mean these
things did you put in this cup we have
two more let's do it in a voice of John
fazenda it's the year 2037 who had the
best overall career out of Lamar Jackson
Baker Mayfield Kyler Murray err I got an
out or Daniel Jones
20:37 who had the best career Lamarr
Baker Cuyler daniel Jones
our Baker Cuyler daniel Jones okay I'm
flying out of the gates with Baker I'm
gonna take Baker that's where my brain
went first is talent around him that
helped true
I just I'm gonna look at the guy I can't
go with Lamar I watched Lamar and I
loved watching him I just every time I
watch them I get so scared he's gonna
get hurt every time I remember the same
way I thought the same way about Mike
Vick and running around on a preseason
game breaking his leg rg3 I was
completely seduced during the rookie
year those guys are running around too
much they get hurt and I don't want to
see it happen to him but I don't know I
can't predict it probably will I I think
my first guess would probably be Baker
but i'ma go I'll go Daniel Jones
already I just think he has something
and I think you know he comes from a
great lineage of a Cutcliffe you know
he's knows how to teach quarterback
there they're thinking their way through
it doesn't necessarily have to have the
strongest heart but he could throw he's
athletic
I think they'll put some talent around
him obviously you ever run it back
when se Kwang gets healthy yeah that's
gonna help him a little bit Adam as
daniel Jones have the Dukas face of all
time
can you name someone who has the Duke
your face Laettner Grayson Allen Jason
Tucker max Grayson Allen is the do
kiyose little Garth
grace now John Shefford Bobby hardly
early cherokees parks you think the
grace is still the dukhia space of all
time he doesn't look like Ted Cruz
that's what I was gonna say all the
white guys from Duke that they all have
the same face in your minds that's right
I'm gonna pick Kyler Murray so why to be
different or be can you believe it no
because I'm sitting here I'm going I
understand what you're saying about
Lamar I believe that Lamar can continue
to make strides I thought he's still
having an issue throwing deep balls and
that's my question about Lamar is is
that accuracy gonna get there I still
think he's so much better than people
think he is but I don't know if he'll
reach the peak I believe that Baker is
the most talented in terms of just
throwing the ball but there's a lack of
elusiveness that I think people thought
he might have yeah Aaron and his his
inability to play well under pressure
right now I need more proof that that's
gonna continue in terms of Daniel Jones
I'm just not getting onboard of him
being the like I don't think his talent
is anywhere close to the other three I
believe that his ceiling is below all of
those guys but his floor might be higher
because he can already throw it better
than Lamar I look at Kyler and this is
still the same [ __ ] team that Josh
Rosen could barely put up three points
with last year and when I saw that
second half against the Lions that's the
reason that they were willing to trade
the seventh pick in the giraffe they
traded up for last year and looking
awful the rest of the media his deep
ball accuracy and some of the touch that
he has they went out there and they
drafted three to four wide receivers and
none of them have hit and I like
Keyshawn Johnson and so so he has no
talent he has 40 year-old Larry
Fitzgerald his offensive line is in
shambles but I still see plays every
week that I go that's some special ass
shin and so because we're looking 20
years from now say Kwan might only be
around for four or five more years and I
hope that doesn't happen but who knows
but I look at Arizona I expect them to
clean house the front office
the
gonna invest a lot more there I just I
think he has the highest ceiling out of
all those guys and right now I actually
prefer my guy to have nothing around him
because the other ones it's hard to
evaluate banker he's not always gonna
have Odell and Jarvis I'll tell you this
though no more I think about Lamar
Jackson I mean he made some things
happen down in Louisville
maybe eight he did man I think he'll
still improve as a quarterback over the
years we're talking about 20 years from
now but as a running type of quarterback
he's probably the best pure runner
Michael Vick obviously defense yes but
he makes people miss in a running back
type of way and it looks not like a
quarterback running which is totally
different than a running back right he
looks like he can so when we talk about
getting hurt and injured
it seems different with him yeah I don't
have fear with Lamar when he runs don't
know because I have never really seen
him take a hard hit he knows how to move
he gets out of bounds but I will say
that what you're saying is why Kyle
scared he is the kind of guy that'll
like wave on a linebacker yeah and not
see someone behind him he doesn't and
that's how quickly it could change I
hope he learns that I mean that's the
part he hath won where do you come out
on the nickname Danny dimes are you in
doing here where you stand on it I use
it I believe he's Daniel dimes and then
when he runs he becomes Danny time is
that true yeah like I believe that he's
only Danny when he runs but he's very
much Daniel when he's in the pocket okay
that's kind of evolves in the middle of
the play he over the attendant he does
either like a switch I tend to look down
on a nickname to use alliteration as a
crutch just D&D I don't like that I
think it's kind of corny I think he
deserves better this is your wheelhouse
yeah listen we were batting it around on
our show the only thing I liked about
Danny dimes is that someone then
suggests that he should be called
Vineyard dimes which is absolutely
perfect with his entire vineyard vom
yeah and let me see shraeger was saying
that dimes are an old currency this is
this is he's all about new in the next
wave and then he should be Danny crypto
which I kind of liked and then I've been
calling him so I was referring to a long
time that Eli was this great dog that
you had and he likes a good dog good dog
and you love him and he does his trick
still but he's kind of walking into
sliding glass doors
he kind
turn into Old Yeller so Danny dimes I've
been calling him new Yeller because he's
the one who actually finally put down
the LDL er well after he should have
been I think so
I don't love Danny dimes but I still
can't land on something that's just
perfect and I fighting I do agree with
you like what you were saying about the
the Duke face dude there's something
there about his attire that I think
could be really made fun of more the
social chair is what he looks like
writes like he locked up walking into
the game he's like the PI Phi's want to
move the fall formal and I got to rebook
the bus's like I didn't Comptroller
good that's good start Santa I'll do it
tomorrow I'll tell you this though guys
have to earn their nicknames okay he
hasn't earned a nickname yet mmm he's
he's Daniel Jones that's who yes I like
you have to earn a nickname in this
league okay but then we need a game just
in case whatever you do to earn a
nickname well you play good or you just
tear up like what if daniel Jones led
like a 20-point comeback and then ran in
a touch out of the end like
overcomplicate and lost his like
starting running back in that game would
that be enough that would that would
that would start that will start the
ball to Roman we'll start thinking about
it you can't call him a nickname until
you produce in this week I just for me
he's such a Daniel that there's nothing
Danny about him that's really part of my
issue at the nickname I guess it's
always bothered me that as athletes that
he looks like fidi
as if we give him like a city name it
would be financial district +5 guys
sounds like a fraternity you know to so
that's perfect
but those athletes who are the Danny's I
never understood that when you become a
grown man like you're still Jimmy and
Tommy and Danny like that always
bothering burr has a theory about these
soon dijo or not deal oh do you have to
be DS something dijo dijo from the block
what's English theory about the Danny's
and Thomas ah that you like you don't
perform well if you have like a kid's
name like Jimmy Garoppolo like shouldn't
he be Jim like little bow-wow
hello she became bow-wow Joey Harrington
little way any KL is there ever been one
that's been fantastic I mean
Oh Tommy Brady but that sound that Benny
Rock so Jimmy Garoppolo would be good I
think Jimmy Garoppolo might be
scrutinies could and that James
Garoppolo sounds incredibly this is like
an error number says Charlie Ward if he
maybe if I'm by Charles Ward he would
have done better
terrible next danny moreno no no not a
chance there really isn't but Andy
Dalton Terence Bradshaw would want even
more Super Bowls right that's a really
good one Inger what do you say to
Terrence Terrence Bradshaw Terry yeah he
said Terry is an actual name not a
nickname alright yeah it's true Billy
yeah I just did Jimmy and the Danny's I
can't take Billy Sims sure he's not a
quarterback but I think it wasn't Philly
Sims you know Phil Simms that's it
police is it your turn now yeah what
voice should he do here Kyle we're
wrapping up um I think you should do
Arnold Schwarzenegger like an easy
impression everybody does everybody can
do it Brian I'm sure you're really good
I'm on come on come on what's random fan
base would be the happiest if their team
won the Superbowl this is the best one
you've done Brian I like this it's
random fan base would be the happiest if
the team on the superbug this year
that's good
see that's like an angry cartoon they
all sound the same like what I when I
when I'm me and my wife my wife is
Panamanian someone I'm making fun of her
dad yeah she's like you sound like an
angry Mexican like are they all sound
that's what they sound like that's all
of my Austrian bodybuilding I'm saying
my dad's accent sound Asian I was
talking to this Russian guy I'm not
gonna do the accent sir yes right so the
question here the question that is a
question was actually which random fan
base would you be the happiest for if
they won so you can't obviously pick
Chicago and you can't pick Philadelphia
I can't pick fell off you or the others
are no much ill of the Niners yeah but
what random fan base if they won would
you actually be very happy for because
this is something that I think you guys
do really well and I really try and
focus on to is like we [ __ ] on
Jacksonville earlier about Jacksonville
won the Superbowl yeah he would be
really happy for that and I think why
but why would you be so happy
what about Jacksonville would you be so
you know I'll share a moment
I went to the Jets Browns game Monday
Night Football stick to football was
doing a podcast out front right had a
bunch of these Jets fans we're having a
huge tailgate and anytime people are
welcoming you to a tailgate it feels
really special sure eat the ribs don't
worry about it all that and they're like
so are you a Jets I said nominee Eagles
fan and one of them stopped me and he
goes you know when you guys won it gave
us hope that we could win okay and they
were like we were texting each other
that night they're like if the Eagles
can do it we can do it and I look I'm an
emotional guy and the podcast I did the
week after I really did I was like
crying on the podcast being like to the
[ __ ] Lions fans because I believe
football is one of those things where it
impacts your identity and for a long
time when I was a Philadelphia fan I was
like this is gonna mirror my life I'll
always think that I have potential to
achieve things but I'm not destined for
something amazing
and I really for me personally I'm a
[ __ ] psychopath when the Eagles won
the Superbowl it made me have more
confidence in my own life I understand
and it really did I was looking down
reading I'm listening like what did you
write down piece of [ __ ] why is he
always crying stuff like cry aloud I'm
in touch with my emotion that's good you
I bet you cry on planes a lot plane you
ever watch a movie on a plane yeah I
cried watching the Queen movie
I cried watching like Hobbes and Shaw
any movie on a plane will make you cry
something about the altitude I'm just
like anyway that guys are the worst
therapy I've ever gotten I liked it so
like when you see fans crying you think
they're crazy no no no when fans say
when you won you make me feel like I
could do bigger and better things in my
life professionally that's what that's
what it is no bro it [ __ ] is I just
that's why this show is great because
you're teaching me about football I'm
teaching about why fans sit outside for
days
or we'll travel to London how does that
make you feel like now you can go be the
best host ever
alright let's really cut into this
[ __ ] a
thousands when you guys went to [ __ ]
for NFC championship games the thing is
is that when I would see the Giants fan
all I would get is [ __ ] destroyed or
the Cowboys fan they're like you don't
have a [ __ ] Ray or loser and ya in
you're a loser you and thus it that's
the reason we get so [ __ ] upset is
because we don't have any control but we
are completely defined by that and so
we're at the mercy of that and the thing
is is my dad never saw a Super Bowl my
grandfather and my grandfather was on
his deathbed and the nurses came rummy
running cuz there was yelling and it was
that one game where you beat the [ __ ]
Vikings and the ball popped up and they
he had not had that much energy for
months and that was like a spring good
to see a Super Bowl and so it's so
engrained into Who I am
I had so many moments of my life where I
couldn't communicate with people
about anything it was like our ideas
were so different what we believed in
our core values but we agreed on the
Eagles like I have friendships where we
have nothing else to talk about except
for that [ __ ] team and I look at it
and then like I go last night I'm
listening to comedians talk about stuff
and one of them is really big in a
philosophy Ryan holiday is gonna be on
the podcast on Saturday and I'd have
nothing to add but I'm it's part of my
life it's [ __ ] weird but I don't know
tell you I think that what actually
makes you know I make fun of you because
it's still funny but yeah III think that
which makes what makes the NFL and their
fans so special though yeah it's [ __ ]
crazy
yeah it's special because that that
feeling that is us we're in the trenches
we're a training camp with you I
remember we don't sugarcoat it
you believed that for a long time that
that whole notion was [ __ ] no I
think that I just I I love the fact that
our fans can associate with us that they
can be with us I just I don't know that
me winning a football game should make
you feel that you can go be veteran life
went viral cuz it was real when the guy
was like I caught a baby
unlike Aguilar and he was like I've been
thinking about it all day right yeah and
that list that Eagles Super Bowl has
been 53 of them that one was unique it
wasn't just like well
got a great team this year we just beat
everybody it was like we got knocked
down and we got back up and you two can
get back up right yeah
your backup quarterback in your life
could women that was a special I think
you could give you some certainly giving
you some some encouragement to say you
know you can kind of do it too like this
I was always a self-motivated type of
guy of course it was always like I just
you're a unicorn Brian you like the guy
know you're special well I don't know
that you know that I'm the reason why
the Bears double don't last year is that
right yeah because I had my shirt off
and I was laying on the couch holding on
to the bottom and the entire fourth
quarter everything was going our way and
you didn't move and then when I did that
he missed it that's commitment is that
true I'm a [ __ ] psycho the answer to
the question about the fan base those
nice look at that at my nose or my mouth
your mouth something believable
you never know sometimes right back in
Buffalo for sure
Buffalo c'mon below is top three Buffalo
I think Buffalo because first of all
Buffalo gots a third base a bunch of
times in a row and never scored it was
just bad enough Buffalo I think a huge
one that if this team won the Superbowl
would blow these people's minds if the
Lions won the Superbowl blow their minds
so he's got two years already and then
one of them that's really hot right now
if the Kansas City Chiefs won the Super
Bowl those people wouldn't know what to
do with themselves because they've been
looked at as losers chokers all that
best barbecue in America and look at
that imagine that the bird tips or
whatever they're called burned ants for
dance if they won their tips was your
hairstyle Tori exactly right Sugar Ray
Sheik that's what I did I was mark
McGrath I think those are my big three
but I I agree with Kansas City now we
look at Kansas City and we almost are
jealous because of what they get to
experience with that offense they're
lottery tickets coming in every fan in
their life in the 90 years of you know
fan of the NFL you should have at least
one year where you have the best player
in the league on your team you have the
best team Chiefs fans have waited for
this 50 years whatever it may be like
this is the golden era from 2019 right
you got mahomes you should go to the
Super Bowl like this is the U and they
put in their time they deserve it yeah
and you don't remember all like people
forget the amount of times they've been
screwed hmm
and not just like in the last decade
like all time yeah sure going way back
I'm just I'm thinking about like the
Andrew Luck comeback
a few years ago did you have anyone
other than his three yeah I had Buffalo
lines
but just just because they've been bad
for so long I got Cincinnati yeah weird
yeah I just kind of want them to win you
kind of want people that have just been
terrible yes
no playoff type wins and you just wanted
to be good I I kind of threw the Browns
in there but they ain't
this team has kind of taken that feeling
away from it just a little bit cuz they
seemed so arrogant and brash as LeBron
bringing a title took some of this yeah
that's right if that had never happened
before and Cleveland had nothing and
they were going back to Jose Mesa and
Ernest Byner that would have been bigger
I'm sorry I'm sorry my self into Detroit
even bigger choice big what about
Oakland that's mine
yeah talk about that Oakland is one of
those teams much like Dallas that we are
in Pittsburgh that when they have a few
years where they're down people like to
say it'll be good at Oakland's better it
the NFL's better in a place when the
Raiders matter yes yeah and so for me if
Oakland were when the Super Bowl that
fan base one they're being they're
having their team taken from them yeah
and I mean I'm thinking if the Raiders
won the Super Bowl right now yeah I mean
more than Gruden Super Bowl speech would
be can you imagine a parade where like a
million people are all knocking if you
hear him like on the street you're right
like card or like anything car windows
are smashing building windows are being
pushed it there would be a lot of people
getting knocked up to I that market
Davis Mark Davis up there like players
getting the confidence to mess with his
hair yeah it's like Jimmie Johnson on
the sideline exactly you mess with the
market super awesome that's gotta happen
this year costumes in the black hole and
do you remember it feeling that way when
they did get to the Super Bowl like it
was it a sensation it was pretty cool I
mean I and maybe we're building it up
more I just always remember the Barret
Robbins an engine John Byrne going boom
yes yeah but if Oakland won I just feel
bad like we're witnessing something that
I didn't think would happen anymore
a city Lehman Ranch oh yeah you know
that really defined a lot of the 90s and
and and all that I just thought Oakland
there's a football team they're getting
supersonic can you imagine that right
sucks but this is it they got to win it
this year it's got to start with Chicago
they got to win this week
I don't think it's happening summer oh
[ __ ] Thank You mr. Kyle Brant this is it
the souvenir takes ourselves but now we
I'm deed the cup and this is I mean this
is why I like you there's one I like you
there's one thing that we can fill it
with hold on we'll do it before I leave
hold on no I did not I did not watch the
video but I may watch it on the train
home right now I think we might watch it
as soon as we get done there you guys
shoot a video of you watching the video
I want to watch the I hit you guys the
best for Brian Westbrook the Rocket Man
you have to have a catchphrase it was
great for Kyle brand for the brand for
the brand doesn't me say for the brand
mcafee so you just I just stole it from
Pat for the brand that's my thing I just
shame on you yeah I love you pat on the
lef koe man and we will holler at you
guys later Warren Sharpe coming up for
Friday peace out homies
[Music]